you know I find it incredible that he's
over here so critical of Kanye West
right about oh he beats his wife
whatever meanwhile you're walking around
with a war criminal has killed hundreds
of thousands of innocent people bomb
them indiscriminately Etc I find it very
interesting people like you are the
problem let's watch this cuz this is so
profound the Unholy shimi with his own
tongue actually shot himself on the
foot by the grace of Allah subhah wa
ta'ala the response has been
overwhelming to say the very least
alhamdulillah we've had social media
personalities and resp Ed Scholars sh
from many parts of the Muslim world
promoting the cause we have raised
almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah and we
haven't been sitting idy waiting to hit
our Target of 2 million we have fully
purchased four properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
taala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves encourage you to stay tuned
for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends don't worries I got injured a
bit uh tripped up and bang my head on
the baby's cut alhamdulillah I'm good
it's not a cut it's not still open but
I'm good guys don't worry my wife sorted
out aldah as you can see with these
whatever they are anyways let's get to
something a bit more important guys okay
focus in the message not on uh that so
let's go we're going to be reacting to
PS Morgan talking about Kenny West and
and the stuff that he said and we're
going to be hearing um myON we're going
to be hearing uh the Unholy sholi and a
few others inshah and there's things
that I quau on I was listening carefully
and I was like like it's just you know
every um accusation is a confession like
sneaker told me once and you are going
to hear this guys you're not going to
believe your ears when you hear this
stuff yeah and again this was news to me
I don't know about what KY said about
you know the Jews and Etc and this is
hate speech and we're against hate
speech to any kind of race religion
whatever they are this is this is a this
is disgusting to put a group of people
no matter what's going on in Israel
we're not going to come put every single
Jew in the same category that's the same
thing that's been done to Muslims let's
get straight into it let's watch this
because this is so profound the Unholy
sholi um with his own tongue actually
shot himself on the foot but I'm going
to come to that later let's watch
inshallah and talk about freedom of
speech uncensored so there's a lot of
things that has been spoken about here
let's get into it straight insh my
people got suspended a lot of it for
harassment hateful conduct and so on so
I think there's literally no dispute or
doubt that he did so the question
remains why was he then not suspended
but able to leave voluntarily but the
wider debate that I think you and I were
having was about freedom of speech and
where that begins and ends I don't want
to put words in your mouth but you seem
to be suggesting that you don't think
there is an end in other words you can
say absolutely anything you want to
which I would say well I don't think you
should be able to say the 32 million
people on a platform that you want to
make Jewish people your slaves and whip
them do you okay interesting so From
This Moment it's very interesting well
do you guys don't believe in absolute
freedom of speech this is where we as
Muslims when we point this hypocrisy out
because as Muslims we have one rule it
doesn't change it doesn't fluctuate as
based on our means and desires we have
one specific rules you don't as
capitalist Western yes uh liberals you
don't have this so now uh Mr freedom of
speech Piers Morgan has boundaries yes
and again I well that I've always said
there is not absolute freedom of speech
you know I'm again against hate speech
you know but anyways let's carry on
let's see what my had to say well I
think um the thing is when Elon took
over X he wanted to mirror it with the
First Amendment and the first amendment
allows a broad range of speech to be
allowed and the reality is we don't have
free speech we don't have a democracy
and that's literally from Elon Musk
himself now if we want to talk about
unequal punishment on X you know based
on some people saying this is getting
punished some people saying this and not
getting punished that's a whole other
conversation but I think if you're going
to mirror the First Amendment uh with
Twitter then you need to allow that
speech in right but but look on the
first point about ex's rules he clearly
transgressed pretty much every rule they
have I think that's unarguable so it's
relon to explain why in the end he was
censored which he was because he posted
legal pornography it seems to me
extraordinary that legal pornography is
deemed to be more offensive and more
worthy of censorship than saying that
you should make Jews your slaves and
whip them so yeah I mean if you look at
El musk again you know somebody who is
going out there and outright talking
about doing this to Jews and do that to
Jews Etc you don't censor him you don't
stop him but the moment he pulls nudity
that's where he draws the line this is
what we mean by subjective morality who
decides what when it's not from the
Divine it's I pick and you and that's
what El musk is doing I mean IL musk the
you know the one who is an ambassador to
Israel now it's all of a sudden now
allow cany West dispute all that
nonsense and hatred which is absolutely
C it's disgusting but the moment he puts
nudity no no no no no okay by the
constant tiate of anti blatantly
anti-semitic garbage that was being
spewed by Kanye West how are you
feeling first of all you're an honorary
Jew because you've really supported
Israel through this war and we're
grateful Pierce tolerating the
Intolerable is the liberalism of fools
you can speak about being a free speech
absolutist but there must be three
exceptions incitement to violence
Commission of violence and admission of
violence incitement admission and he
mentioned another thing let's stick that
very carefully because now he has
putting himself in deep Waters because
so he's basically saying somebody who
condones or calls towards violence okay
let's see um if Rabbi sholi and H sh has
done that listen carefully listen very
carefully so what's missing from this
discussion is not that Kanye said that
Jews should be whipped it's that Kanye
said that he has beaten women and he
said that women should be slapped and
his wife is in an abusive relationship
and Bianca sori's family who live in
Melbourne Australia have done nothing to
rescue her are we talking about whether
there should be prnography at unx there
was pornography at the Grammys lip
professional leap lip readers had him
tell his wife Bianca sorri take your
mink coat off and she has is totally
glass eyed there's no there is no free
agency she is an abused wife she's an
abused woman how is the media becoming
complicit in the absolute degradation
and humiliation of this woman okay
interesting so Unholy shimoli cares
about woman all woman he talking about
talking about all woman okay what about
the Palestinian woman what about the
Palestinian woman who are hostages in
Israel those hostages they were hostages
as well not just they not pres hostages
yeah being graped yes that your country
is honoring these individuals who have
been doing that not only raping men and
not women also men what about that you
[__] you Unholy shimoli what about that
oh no you wouldn't would you cuz now you
are indirectly condoning violence like
you said yes you are indirectly Condon
vience it's okay when you do it let's
carry on bring you back in because
yesterday when you were getting into it
with me about what you perceive to be
censorship you said why the [__] are you
calling for censorship when you have a
show called uncens the hypocrisy is
incredible but I was calling for a
censorship of blatant threatening
violence in the language abuse of Jewish
people and of women including trying to
Market a t-shirt based around an
incident of criminal domestic abuse that
I surely you would agree with that
censorship wouldn't you no I I don't
believe in censorship I think uh you
know context matters and it's very
obvious that you know he's doing this as
a marketing plug I mean look we're
talking about it right now so he's done
a fantastic job he had a commercial with
the Super Bowl he's the Talk of the Town
right now he's basically stolen the
attention from Kendrick Lamar some
people here are trying to say that
Kendrick is more relevant than Kanye
when it comes to Hip Hop but he's stolen
the attention how from really smart
marketing now with that said um I don't
think anyone's ability to speak should
ever be censored now do I like
everything that he says no but I'm going
to fight for his ability to say it I
also think it's important to note that
sarcasm and humor and uh making jokes is
a part of what he was saying does is he
really going to run around and slap
women no obviously he's being sarcastic
he's being fun he's being edgy and I
think that's important because we need
people like that pushing the envelope so
we could Protect free speech but he was
literally he was literally trying to
sell a t-shirt which had imagery of his
friend Diddy his new friend apparently
because they fell out his friend Diddy
involved in a criminal act of abuse
against a woman
literally that's what he was doing yeah
I mean it's America hang on say just to
be clear though just to be clear Mar you
think that you think that was
acceptable again capitalism is
capitalism do I agree with it do I like
it maybe not however I will support his
ability to do it because he's obviously
marketing things he thinks he's maybe he
has some dark humor that he wants to do
where he thought that was funny but the
reality is that this is America and the
capitalism is a thing here so when Elon
Musk can I hang hang hang on one sec
I'll come to all of you so when just to
be clear Mar when Elon Musk replied
yesterday to someone on X and said that
he was now being censored for the legal
pornography that he was posting did you
agree with that well I don't like
pornography but again um it is legal uh
there's a three-part test in America
with the Miller test to see if it
suffices and you know you can make the
argument that you know it they didn't
cause any issues as far as was wrong to
censor
him with pornography yes well again I
don't like porn I don't think it should
be on X at all personally okay so so you
agree with
censorship for pornography right but let
be clear you agree with censorship no I
agree with pornography not being on X I
think it needs to be contained in a
certain way well here I have to be
honest and be like well hold on a second
now this what mean about capitalism
talking about capitalism and this is the
reason why many people lost their lives
because of Boeing Boeing was rushing
production because they were in
competition with Airbus and because of
that they were U trying to get you know
their sh shareholders to have the
maximum amount of profits they rushed it
so much that they had a a a failure in
um manufacturing these planes that had a
faulty uh thing which caus the plane to
dive down or something like that which
caus two or three of these um the
airplanes to crash because of capitalism
because it's all about Prophet they
don't care about human life and here you
can see two people one's talking about
uncensored he's sensoring people the
other one saying nothing should be
sensored then he's saying no pornography
should be sensed I agree with him pory
should be sensored but now you're saying
you're advocate for uncensorship you
hav't go P Morgan for censoring people
He's a hypocrite as well but then
yourself you're saying that pornography
should be censored this is what happens
when you don't have objective morality
but let's carry on because my main thing
here is catching out Unholy shimoli look
what he says we're going to come to insh
I also like Elon Musk and I'm very
grateful to him for having gone to
Israel right after the October 7th
attacks being escorted by the prime
minister of Israel himself Benjamin nany
to see the women that were raped that
were beheaded families that were burnt
alive I was there one week after the
attacks as well but I also agree with
you that this is absolutely unacceptable
I saw your Tweet Pierce and that's why I
wanted to come on the show you know zuie
and wait wait just a second zuie and you
seem like very decent guys you can
respond let me let me let me please let
me speak I believe respectfully that
this interview will live in shame for
the two of you for the duration of your
careers my friend it's going to be in
shame for you not just them whatever you
want to accuse him of also you you
double standard hypocrite you double
standard hypocrite K Watch what he says
guys just watch what he says you myON
that he was joking when he said he beats
up women haha I beat my wife Bianca and
that's funny what is funny about beating
up a woman what is funny about
threatening violence against a people
who in the lifetime of my mother were
gassed at a rate of 10,000 a day and
turned into Ash this interview
respectfully will be on your highlight
career living in infamy what's funny
about Palestinians who are being
massacred in the thousands 45 50,000
plus people massacred what's funny about
that your nation your people are
laughing mocking saying that if we could
have a button to erase Gaza we would do
it and you yourself have condoned that
violence how we're going to catch you
very shortly now watch very carefully
guys because he slips up so badly look
what he repeats in history and he does
exactly the damn same thing watch
carefully it is not funny to murder 1.5
million children it is not funny to
Rampage through the Jewish Community
surrounding Gaza beheading Jews and
non-jews including Tha workers with
Spades I saw their beheaded bodies for
God's sake There's real consequences to
this hate there used to be an alliance
between the black and Jewish communities
knowing that we were hated for no reason
other than the fact that we were
different dear your response to Rabbi
schy yeah again you know I find it
incredible that he's over here so
critical of Kanye West right about oh he
beats his wife whatever meanwhile you're
walking around with a war criminal has
killed hundreds of thousands of innocent
people bomb them indiscriminately Etc I
find it very interesting that you're so
hardcore on Twitter about some tweets
that may or may not have been a joke
more than likely a joke anyone that has
Common Sense sarcasm dark humor Etc
versus you're running around with
someone that's literally a war criminal
wanted by the ICC that's killed tens of
of innocent children right and then
you're over here calling for censorship
I'm tired of anti-Semitism I'm tired of
racism people like you are the [__]
problem because here's the thing
Americans are tired of censorship we're
tired of being brow beat into being
virtue singling losers like you I could
not say better I'm so sorry with this
you are basically stive selective
outrage selective outrage oh woman's
rights oh this how can I do that but the
same thing when it comes to the
Palestinians ah what do you do you do
the same thing if not similar to keny
West yeah tell me tell me I'm wrong and
try to raise me say oh you go ahead and
you provoke problems with people I've
literally seen you do this you go up to
people you provoke them and they tell
you [__] off and then you get mad and
you yell anti-Semitism quite literally
what I want to hear is this Rabbi Shi
until you can actually call people Liars
for what they say no one cares about
anti-Semitism anymore you guys run
around use it for everything we're tired
of it stop trying to brow beat us in
virtue signal saying oh that's
anti-semitic how about this when you can
call someone a liar for what they're
saying then we'll start taking you more
seriously other than that you're [__]
dildo Rabbi all right there you go you
know what could you uh what could you
say to that you know they have destroyed
anti-Semitism is a real thing and we we
are against any anyone thus anti-semitic
but the zionists have been the biggest
anti-semites the biggest anti they go
against Jews who speak the truth so you
my friend are the biggest anti-semite
yourself you know but anyways Jim Crow
and segregation outlived slavery you had
white racists especially the clan who
basically told white men that these
black men want to defile your women the
Germans said the same thing about Jewish
men in Germany now that's one of the
things that people feel most strongly
about I have to protect my women I have
to protect my wife then we saw lynchings
choke no joke made a very good point we
saw all these lynchings those lynchings
were a direct reaction to look at Emil
Emil was 14 years old arguably the most
famous lynching in American history they
cut off his penis and put it into his
mouth we now have his coffin at the
Smithsonian National Black History
Museum because they said that he
whistled at a white woman even a
14-year-old boy wanted to rape a black
woman now was that incitement to
violence of course it was the clan is
all about incitement to violence when
the clan says that the the black Man by
voting is going to take over the entire
South and take your women and take your
jobs that is incitement to violence
that's why zuie with all due respect
you're just being too General you're not
giving any strict categories here okay
listen carefully now he's saying that in
history there was a young black boy for
that matter who was accused of whistling
towards a white girl and what did the
the the the KKK and those who were white
supremist done they lynched him they
killed him they his private part put in
his mouth so he's saying that when
people want to do acts of violence they
do it indirectly by using woman woman
you know this is what they've done to
our women to our kids because men in
their nature they are protective against
their woman folk that's within our
nature so usually people who want to
commit acts of violence to others they
usually do what use lies to propagate a
specific thing so people can get angry
because when it comes to women and kids
like we know the whole situation when it
comes to the grooming Etc uh the
accusations against specific minorities
that are doing that Etc w we have Peter
files on a rampant white mid pu M
nobody's look yeah okay because it's
their own doing it so he's saying that
people do that there's truth to that and
that is true and that happened in
history but he missed something else he
and Israel and zus do exactly the same
thing listen to this carefully so the
moment you start saying that Nan is
Hitler that is where Kanye West West
begins to win Churchill is Hitler and
Nan is Hitler and now we can no longer
distinguish between good and evil
between free societies fighting to stop
the gang rape of women and the beheading
of children versus Kamas who preaches
the gang rap I don't want to get I don't
want to get into the he just done EX
actly what he was accusing that people
in history the white supremist and
whoever it is to do to dehumanize a
specific group so they can be attacked
you my friend just done the same thing
by the lies of the grapes that never
happened by the um babies that were
beheaded that never happened your
Society you and you are repeating the
same retoric that is a lie that's been
proven to be a lie and you are talking
about in history how black individuals
whatever it is they will used and false
rumors were sent to act violence so you
are literally causing um violence to
happen indirectly when you came and said
you know there's conditions to freedom
of speech you know if you are condoning
violence or calling towards violence
directly or indirectly you my friend and
your uh country that is stolen Israel
yes you guys are doing exactly the same
thing to the Palestinians by
dehumanizing them so the world can
justify you committing a massacre you
[__] you're saying with your own mouth
that's all I have to say guys I'm not
going to carry on nothing else needs to
be said this guy's are absolute [__]
for that matter and that's all I'm going
to say brother sisters you saw how he
shot himself in his own foot and again
candy west what he said I'm totally
against it this is against Islam yes to
act VI call violence against group of
people yes um and there's many of look I
don't agree with P Morgan I don't agree
with totally with myON there some truth
that he said he are not all I don't
agree no way with Unholy shoi so you can
see the double stand this guys that's
all I wanted to bring to your attention
may Allah bless and preserve you guys
till next time